I've been doing it for a very long time
and I enjoy working with people that are
in serious problems and it's a great
thing to be able to give back to society
to go and work I work in some very nice
hospitals in London but to actually go
to a war zone and to go and help people
there is I feel one of the best things I
can possibly do with my life I've done
it since four since 1993 in Bosnia and
I've done it three times a year almost
for the past 23 years but I think that
the most enjoyable things I've been
doing more recently really is to
training and teaching the doctors and
I've used the knowledge that I've gained
over 20 years or so and put it back into
training courses and using all the
videos and pictures of operations that
I've done over those years and actually
now training people how to do it so I
leave a legacy and that's the most
fantastic part of what I do now I was
operating in one of the frontline
hospitals in Aleppo in 2013 and one of
the fighters was in our Hospital who was
shot in the chest and had a chest
trained put in and he went upstairs to
the ward and I went to see him and he
was obviously very unwell and was
becoming very shocked and out of the
chest rain there was about a liter and a
half two liters of blood so he had to go
down to the operating theatre and we had
to do an operation called a thoracotomy
to open his chest and so we did do this
and I was taking through one of the
Syrian the young Syrian surgeons who'd
never done one before and showing him
how to do it and as we were just
starting the operation the doors of the
operating theatre burst open and about
six fighters came in all dressed in
black with them a que forty-sevens and
it was that moment when I suddenly
realized that they were Isis fighters
and we were operating on a an Isis
fighter as well but you have to put all
those things to your back in the back of
your mind and you have to then just
concentrate on the patient themselves
because that patients a human being and
as a humanitarian your job is to help
human beings and that's what we did it's
much worse now when I was in - in 2014
when I was in Aleppo is pretty bad then
there are lots of barrel bombs
being dropped on the eastern part of a
city where I was working
indiscriminately so we were having lots
of civilians children and ladies coming
in very badly injured but the situation
now is absolutely intolerable in the
past month or so or the past six months
when since Russia has been involved
there's basically carpet bombing of
Aleppo City itself the city is such that
there was a bomb being dropped every 17
minutes
I understand last week last weekend was
the worst weekend they'd ever had it had
over 350 people killed a thousand people
injured and of those three and 50 killed
there was 50 children killed as well and
I was sitting at home receiving all
these pictures are from whatsapp of the
injuries that they had they were asking
me things like they'd never seen things
before children with ball bearings in
their various parts of their body and
then they found out that one of these
ball bearings had actually come from a
Russian cluster bomb because it hadn't
exploded and rolled into the hospital
and they opened it up and inside that
was loads of ball bearings so cluster
bombs are being dropped all over a
civilian population and not only that
the hospitals themselves are being
targeted the hospital where we did this
amazing Skype operation three weeks ago
was totally and utterly destroyed last
week with five bombs two rockets and one
of those big bunker bombs which has
totally destroyed it and so there is no
hope then left for the people around
that area and in fact there's only one
or two hospitals left functioning at all
there's not much time left to help these
people we have about six weeks to do
something in because the American
population themselves are now looking
forward to their presidential elections
their diplomacy has broken down
completely between Russia now so un
diplomatically unfortunately have also
broken down so what's left well the only
people that are left are the European
countries and I hope that the United
Kingdom and all the other European
countries together
could put forward a contingent that will
actually go and visit President Putin
many people have told me David it's
pointless doing that but I think we have
to show something we have to show that
we care we have to show that we're not
going to let this happen complete
disregard of international humanitarian
law and Geneva Conventions we cannot
allow it to happen
and we're going to be looked back on in
history I think in the future of being
perhaps complicit with what's going on
because we just didn't do anything and
that's the biggest tragedy of the whole
problem I think they will be held
complicit they knew what was going on
they did absolutely nothing the only
person that's doing something at the
moment is Andrew Mitchell as a member of
the Parliament but everybody else are
just sitting on their hands doing
nothing and unfortunately it would look
like that in a year or so time